even by the standards of superhero
comics supergirls long history is truly
weird from her ill-fated romances to
being obliterated from existence and
replaced by a blob of protoplasm that
used to sleep with Lex Luthor here are
the most unbelievably bizarre pieces of
supergirls buckwild history the single
weirdest thing about Supergirl might be
that she didn't show up for a full 20
years after the creation of Superman
despite introducing Superboy in 1944 and
Krypto the Superdog in 1955 DC Comics
wouldn't get around to even a tempting
Supergirl for another three years after
that when they finally did get around to
this whole Supergirl thing she was
originally introduced as a one-off
character not only was this version not
Superman's cousin she actually died at
the end of the story and was never seen
again
the first version the one with the - and
her name showed up in 1958 Superman
number 123 when Superman's pal Jimmy
Olsen found a magic Genie belt and
wished her into existence after a few
encounters in which she and Superman
kept getting in each other's way
Supergirl wound up exposing herself to
kryptonite and then begging Jimmy to end
her hellish existence pretty dark
despite her unfortunate and this
Supergirl served as a prototype for the
Girl of Steel that would be introduced
the following year after readers
responded well to the idea like
Supergirl
Cara's relative and experienced with her
powers would be a frequent plot point
and visually they were almost
indistinguishable super girls costume
was not only similar to what readers
would see it's virtually identical to
the one Melissa Benoist would wear on
the Supergirl TV show almost 60 years
later in 1959 Action Comics number 252
told the story of the Supergirl from
Krypton and introduced readers to
Supergirl for real this time it was Kara
zor-el Superman's cousin whose family
had survived the destruction of Krypton
when their home Argo city was blasted
into space as a single intact chunk of
the planet unfortunately the explosion
turned Argo city into kryptonite
poisoning the inhabitants and leading
zor-el to follow in his brother's
footsteps by packing his kid into a
rocket and shooting her to earth all
things considered that's a pretty
plausible origin story by Superman
standards the weirdest part of the story
is that Cara gets a pretty cold
reception from her cousin for two
decades worth of stories Superman had
believed himself to be the only survivor
of his home planet a
in the universe finally he has a
connection to Krypton someone else who
has lost her entire family and culture
at first he's welcoming and then she
asked if she can come live with him
Superman's responses to reviews on the
basis of his secret identity being in
jeopardy in other words he doesn't want
her cramping his style at his bachelor
pad instead he gives her a wig and drops
her off in an orphanage
that's how superman deals with his only
living relative in the universe by the
large super girls adventures in the 50s
and 60s tended to follow the same
pattern as Superman's at least at first
her first major love interest was dick
Malvern a classmate who liked Lois Lane
and Lana Lang before him suspected
Cara's secret identity and tried to
trick her into revealing herself as time
went on though super girls life got
truly weird in addition to a
long-running romance with a cyborg from
the future super girls primary romantic
interest was a horse
specifically comet the superhorse just
wait it gets crazier comet had actually
been a centaur back in Hercules time who
through a combination of curses and
bizarre events wound up living in space
for a couple thousand years as a
bulletproof flying horse who still had
sentience whenever a specific comet came
close to Earth though the magic would
turn him fully human for a few days so
naturally he kept all of this secret
from Supergirl assumed the human
identity of a rodeo rider Bronco Bill
star and dated Supergirl without ever
telling her who he was no romantic
relationship in comics has ever even
gotten close to being that weird as you
might have heard 1979 saw the release of
Superman the movie which was kind of a
big deal with Christopher Reeves
performance as the Man of Steel
audiences loved the movie which launched
DC's flagship character into a full-on
franchise by the mid 80s and the release
of Superman 3 enthusiasm for the
Superman films had waned a bit but they
were still successful enough to warrant
a spinoff
thus Supergirl which attempted to
recapture the magic and expand
Superman's movie universe and didn't
quite managed to pull it off while Helen
Slater received a fair amount of praise
in the title role the movie itself was
pretty weird for one thing it had very
little connection to the other Superman
films the only actor to appear in both
was Mark McClure as Jimmy Olsen without
him in a cameo for Reeve even stranger
was the plot the film pitted Supergirl
against Faye Dunaway as an inspiring
witch named Selina who
gets her hands on a Kryptonian artifact
called the omegahedron and tries to use
it to summon demons still Slater's
wide-eyed earnestness in the part has
its appeal and her connection to the
character has remained strong throughout
the decades since Slater would go on to
play Superman's mother Lara on
Smallville
Superman's adopted mom Eliza Danvers on
Supergirl and even voiced Superman's mom
Martha Kent in an animated film in 1986
DC Comics launched an ambitious attempt
to restructure their entire universe
with a year-long event called crisis on
Infinite Earths the main idea was to
eliminate some of the aspects that
readers had come to regard as hokey and
overcomplicated condensing confusing
timelines down to a single streamlined
universe given that he had a longer and
more convoluted history than anyone else
on the DC Comics roster it's not
surprising that the Superman books went
through the biggest overhaul along with
recasting Lex Luthor as a deeply corrupt
billionaire businessman the big changes
came in the form of a new origin for
Clark Kent's that reestablished him as
the true last Son of Krypton in the new
continuity he was now the only survivor
of the planets explosion and eliminated
the idea that he had his full powers
before he was an adult that meant no
Superboy no Krypto the Superdog no comet
the superhorse and no Supergirl to give
the character an ending rather than just
writing her out of the books crisis on
Infinite Earths saw Kara sacrifice in
her life in order to save Superman and
with him countless billions of innocent
lives the thing is the way the effects
of crisis were resolved in the books she
wasn't a dead hero who was remembered in
honor instead in the new DC Universe
she'd simply never existed there was
however an epilogue 2-car a story that
cropped up in a pretty unexpected place
in 1989's Christmas with the super
heroes a holiday anthology with a
handful of stories the ghostly Deadman
lamented the fact that while he could
briefly possess the living he'd always
leave them with no memory of his heroic
deeds while he dealt with those feelings
a ghostly woman showed up and told him
that heroism isn't done for recognition
in the final panels of the story the
woman gives her name is Cara and while
it doesn't mean anything to dead man it
meant a lot to the readers crisis had
done its level best to get rid of
concepts like Superboy Supergirl in
crypto but if you're familiar with
superhero stories at all it probably
won't surprise you to learn that
literally
all of it eventually came back even
putting aside the nostalgia that a new
generation of creators had for their
favorites copyrights on characters like
Supergirl are very valuable and if
they're not being used they can fall out
of the control of the companies that own
them supergirls returned to the comics
page isn't surprising the fact that she
did it's in less than two years however
is pretty surprising to be fair this
wasn't Cara zor-el instead this
Supergirl was a shape-shifting
protoplasmic matrix created in an
alternate pocket dimension by a morally
good Lex Luthor who made her look like
his dead ex-girlfriend and gave her all
of Superman's powers plus turning
invisible she then came to the regular
DC earth and moved in with Superman's
parents who called her May short for
matrix and she became the new Supergirl
she then moved in with Lex Luthor - who
was actually the regular evil Lex Luthor
who had transplanted his brain into a
cloned body and told everyone that he
was his own son a few years later she
symbiotically bonded with a dead
teenager and split into a good matrix
and an evil matrix and might also have
been an angel good thing we had that
crisis thing huh this new stuff was way
easier for new readers to understand
then she's Superman's cousin if you
think the post-crisis Supergirl was
complicated get ready because we're
about to talk about Power Girl right
from the start she's a little more
complicated but the short version is
that before crisis DC's multiverse
contained a dimension called earth -
where they stuck all the characters from
the 40s who had been rebooted in the 50s
and 60s whenever they showed up they
were always presented as being a decade
or two older than their mainstream
earth-1 counterparts giving a home to
characters like the original flash Green
Lantern and Superman Superman still had
a cousin on that earth but earth 2's
Cara zor-el didn't go by Supergirl
instead this older version went by Power
Girl with a completely different costume
for some reason Power Girl was
considered to be more necessary for the
post-crisis DC Universe and managed to
stick around once the universe was
streamlined the thing is Power Girl was
an alternate version of a character who
no longer existed from a universe that
no longer existed whose entire reason
for being had been completely eliminated
the post-crisis Power Girl could no
longer be Superman's cousin and creators
spent the next 20 years trying to figure
out what her deal was the first big
solution was that she was actually the
granddaughter of a wizard from the lost
continent of Atlantis who put her in a
magic crystal for forty five thousand
years then she got pregnant and gave
birth to a magic rapidly aging baby who
is never seen again
then she was a major character in a teen
book that when it got cancelled was
revealed to have been a fantasy drawn in
a child's coloring book then she was
just Superman's cousin again simple I
missed out on the whole thing to be
honestly I was confused by it I'm very
confused by though I was very confused
by the whole thing to be if I'm being
honest if the concept of matrix
Supergirl wasn't weird enough 1996 saw
the launch of a new Supergirl series in
which Supergirl gained a new secret
identity this time it was Linda Danvers
a young woman who had unfortunately been
kidnapped and sacrificed to the devil
before her first comic ever
started matrix found her body and
overwhelmed with grief bonded with her
merging her protoplasmic form and
personality with Linda's becoming a new
Supergirl in the process a little ways
into the run Supergirl spontaneously
developed the ability to sprout fiery
wings and the book began to feature
Wallace Johnson aka Wally the god boy a
boy who claimed he was God it eventually
turned out that Linda was an earth born
angel and that bonding with matrixes
super-powered protoplasm had allowed her
human form to contain this divine
essence at this point Supergirl was an
angel who was also a teenage devil
worshiper who was also a blob from
another dimension who was also somehow
still connected to Superman it wouldn't
surprise you to learn that after a few
years of this they got rid of this
Supergirl and introduced another one who
was just Superman's cousin from Krypton
her name is Kara zor-el from Krypton
she's my cousin
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superheroes are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]